there's a couple here on your list that
aren't on the list actually that maybe I
I I want to get your thoughts in and
around um first one being dating older
women you know I fell into this trap I
think in my mid to late 20s it's like
maybe things weren't going as well as I
wanted to you know I was having a little
bit of success but it's like oh this
older woman she's more secure she's more
successful she's doing bigger things
she's into me like and I would latch on
to these things and I see a lot of young
guys that are in their 20s fall into
that way of thinking what are your
thoughts around men in their 20s dating
older women yeah I see that a lot I've
had I've had quite a few you guys
calling in my podcast and like hey you
know I'm 27 and I'm dating this 41y old
and she's super hot and she's a smoke
show she's got a teenage son or
something like that and it's like and
then follows you know the problems that
ensue and it's like dude you realize you
can avoid all of those problems if you
don't date an older woman that's got
some kid or kids right like you know
your sexual strategy is to pass down
your seat like that's why you're on the
earth is to scatter your seat and you're
abandoning that to deal with a woman
who's past your fertility stage I mean
let's be honest she's not going to give
you any children you're going to be
responsible for raising some other
dude's kid and at the end of the day
you're not really able to lead a
relationship if you're 27 and she's 41
right because she's always going to look
down on you right she's always going to
be that uh woman that's like you know
well I got divorced five years ago and I
got half his [__] and I'm sorted I got
my money right but I like this guy
because he's young and he's hard right
like that's that's what their angle
tends to be is I'm an older woman um I'm
not getting what I want in my age range
I've already got my money because I took
half of his [__] when I got divorced so
I'm just going to date a young and hard
guy sort of thing right and that's
that's usually what happens and it's a
lot of sex and like enthusiastic monkey
sex and they like it and guys are very
simple right like guys are very very
easy to please if you have an
enthusiastic generally attractive woman
they usually get like you know the post
divorce breast augmentation done so they
got like the tailor made titties going
on and everything looks good sort of
thing like just touch the their pee PE
and they'll fall for you right younger
guys fall for it all the time and it's a
trap you know it's the soul Crusher 3000
is what I call it so you know try it out
have some fun if you need to explore
some options but do not do not make a
long-term relationship out of it do not
marry her because I'm telling you like
you're 27 now but when you're 37 she's
going to be 51 and women go downhill
rapidly when they hit menopause right
and that happens for some women in their
early 40s sometimes you know their early
50s but somewhere in and around that 10
to 15E Mark her her looks are are going
to decline rapidly and if we're being
honest like a woman's value to a guy is
her fertility you know like can like can
she bring him children and there's
absolutely no way you're going to get
that from an older woman yeah and guys
if you're looks money sadest game or not
on point you're not in the top 20% and
you're you know falling into these traps
like pull back get focused on you Excel
grow Chase greatness and you're have no
problem attracting the the the younger
women the problem is is that it's loow
hanging fruit it's really really easy
right it's it's really easy for a young
you know 20-year-old guy to get an older
check it's it's just super easy so you
know they think oh wow you know this
this woman actually gets me like you
know she understands me and she's super
attracted to me but Becky that I dated
last year that was my age or slightly
younger she ran off with uh Tyrone or
Chad or whatever and I haven't seen her
since so because she's given me all this
attention I'll just look past the fact
that she's older yeah yeah she's playing
your brother become Chad uh the other
one on here maybe because the book was
written a few years back um this might
be more of an issue that's kind of rose
up in the last year or two um but
plastic surgery uh women that have
highly um surg surgical modified faces
I'll share a story here with you rich if
you're okay with it so I was at an event
a couple weeks back it was big charity
nonprofit kind of you know High Society
like the who's who of Tampa all is in
there um about 400 people showed at the
event walked in with the woman that I
was with and insing one of the first
things I said is there's a plastic
surgeon in Tampa that has has made
millions of dollars off of this room
it's all the same look it's the high
cheekbones it's the chin it's the nose
it's the eyes it's the lips I mean it's
almost a mold and you could literally
see it across the entire room now later
on in the evening as the party kind of
ascended we moved on to the after party
the woman host running the event I'm
close friends with her her dad was there
comes up to me and the woman I was there
with at the event she goes ah it's so
refreshing to see a beautiful woman that
hasn't had her face modified and hacked
up just your thoughts man around this
like for me that's a big big warning
sign if you can see that there's been a
massive amount of work done on her face
because I don't think that ever ends I
think once they go down that that hole
it's an endless Pursuit what what are
what are your thoughts around plastic
surgery in the face yeah I always find
that funny because women push back so
hard when I tell them that you're a
beauty object to a man like I run this
podcast now my unplugged Alpha podcast
series called ladies night I've only
been doing it for a few months and they
get so bent out of shape that um that
that their value is primarily associated
to their looks and their beauty oh why
can't I'm like you know why is my value
just attached to that like why can't you
appreciate me for my degrees or my
accomplishments my career and all those
things and I tell them the same thing
there's no guy that's ever looked at
your degree and been like oh yeah look
at the degree on that girl right that's
that's not what we're looking at So to
that point you know women are Beauty
objects and they know this they
inherently know this and anytime they
tell themselves it's not true or I
should be admired for more than my
beauty why do they spend all this time
and money on Botox and lifters and
ejections and boob jobs and spanks and
push-up bras and high heels and all of
these things to make themselves and
dying their hair and the eyelash
extensions and their like you can go on
and on and on women spend a vast fortune
on trying to preserve maintain and delay
the onset of gravity and time with their
beauty so I think it's an unfortunate
thing because there's some genuinely
attractive women that can age into their
30s 40s and 50s you know for example and
still look very attractive without doing
all that nonsense I think some basic
fundamental care like eye cream maybe
you know if you get older and you want
to tighten the skin back you know and it
doesn't look weird um but like when they
get to like the lip fillers where they
can't laugh and they're you know they
look like a fish or their or their
eyebrows can't can't move you know
because their forehead's Frozen from all
the Botox it's not a good look and
somebody needs to tell these women the
truth you look like trash like it
doesn't look good um maybe there's some
guys that like that I just don't happen
to be one of them yeah um Richard this
is something I spent a lot of time on
because you know my world is kind of
engulfed in the pornography addiction
space and when you you know you talk
about supernormal stimulus you know
there's a great study that's was done in
Stanford with the with the butterfly
ecosystem where they injected these fake
butterflies that had bigger Wings
brighter color um eyes and whatnot and
the the male butterflies stopped going
to the female butterflies to mate they
started going to the artificial ones I
see what's happening in society maybe
this is my skewed perception because I
spent so much time talking with men that
are wrapped up in pornography that what
women are doing is a byproduct of men
being overly
uh not not sexualized but overly
stimulated through just an endless
stream of women after women after women
I mean you know like I've heard Jordan
Peterson talk about this that a
12-year-old boy today in a span of five
or 10 minutes can look at consume and
watch more naked women than a king would
have done you know hundred years ago so
I think that what women are doing
because women follow men right like men
are becoming more attracted to these
fake things you have cartoon porn you
have all that kind of you know the BBW
and all these other things I see this as
this is what's happening because men are
and and and we're getting caught up in
that but that's just my perception
around these things but it's not
attractive to me at all and it's it's
once you see it it's like I you can't
unsee it and like I said I've seen so
many women that they'll start with the
nose but then it's the cheeks and then
it's the jaw and then it's the lips and
then it's the eyes and it's like because
every time they change something they're
not liking the person that they're
seeing back so it becomes this endless
almost facial body dysmorphia type of
type of Life yeah there's a book by
Maxwell malz called psychos cybernetics
and he was into rhinoplasty this is this
book's old it's decades old and he was
you know he's talking about in the book
how he noticed that even after doing
like facial reconstructive surgery for
guys that were in like burn victims or
anything like this um no matter how good
the results how perfect they looked
after the fact um their Mind's Eye like
the vision they held of themselves was
was still the deformed look that they
always had right so I think that's just
one of the flaws you know with human
thinking um I honestly like I get why
women do it and I see the industry
exists and there's a lot of push to
encourage and endorse that and I mean
some some some self-care is good like I
want a woman to look fit and feminine
and I get look hey maybe you know time
and gravity haven't been good you want
to get a breast augmentation fine I mean
but when it gets to the point where it's
like you know she walks in the room and
her tits enter the room like three
seconds before the rest of her because
they're so big then it kind of gets
exaggerated right like you know like
take care of yourself but don't go so
far that it looks obnoxious and I don't
know maybe some some some women the way
that guys to some degree get addicted to
porn and like going down the rabbit hole
or whatever that looks like women might
get you know addicted to the notion of
like facial you know uh surgeries and
lifts and Botox and injectors and all
these sorts of things and you know fine
it's just you know I want you to eat
you're just not going to eat at my
table yeah all for the selfcare man uh
Healthy nutrition hydration water intake
you know get regular facials for women
right you know strength train build
muscle like you know
Muses exactly there's a lot of things
that you can naturally do to keep
yourself looking young and and beautiful
I really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full length
podcast you can find that over here that
clip's from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace out